citizens of the reject Nation we are
diving deeper into the tomorrow verse
with Green Lantern beware my power
I'm very excited to watch this because
uh we jumped around the tomorrow's a
little bit but now we're on a path yeah
we started with Batman and now we're on
track so we're getting there and and I
think you mentioned uh our first Green
Lantern title that's right the first
solo Green Lantern joint it's crazy
we've watched like 20 of these yeah
these are always Nathan Philly and so
excited to see you again just now here
yeah so we're excited uh we want to
thank our friends over at prepper for
helping this edit exist we want to thank
our patrons for watching it unedited
from front to back beginning to end with
our resting watching faces
and we want to thank all of you for
liking subscribing and commenting and
all of the things you do on the YouTubes
to keep this pager going you guys have
been loving these so we love doing them
please keep commenting and letting us
know what you want to notch next and
we'll keep making them because they're a
good time so without further Ado let's
beware our power green
[Music]
kind of driving through a city I mean
we're driving yeah
there are cars
very ripped from the headlines
bam
[Music]
oh it's Jon Stewart moving
we told you to leave this Sally
oh jeez man and now you pay the price
we're gonna light you on fire
oh God they really are
oh but where are my power Green Lanterns
lied
you want to play bodyguard for this
garbage
everyone's dead dead dead the end is
nigh washman's been off there's a
Watchman anime movie coming up oh look
out
yes this will go well
this guy's a medal of honor winner
citation list a mile long do we really
want to risk getting heat from social
media or the Press gamers are so hard to
satisfy that's true that's true it's got
those medals all those Medal of Honor
tournaments
jeez I found you John
how do you know me
please still I'm going to take you to
the hospital the Galaxy is on Orion's
oh no oh
no it's very efficient for burials
though Jesus
come with your own funeral pyre a lot
less waste Ash is immediately scattered
yeah efficiency
it's drawn to you Jon Stewart to Earth
Fair you possess singular will welcome
to the Green Lantern Corps wow
get off of me
sweet you are tasked with halting five
genocides in this sector then you must
stop the balishian war pound sand ring
pounds sand
oh no oh no
damn a minute
is there someone who would know what to
do in this situation affirmative can you
show them to me
whoa I love that it just dictates this
to you yeah it's like you're a lantern
now tough deal with it what's that up
ahead it is called the Justice League
Watchtower they did form that little
team after all oh yeah oh that's right
there wasn't no Green Lantern I don't
think and will Batman have joined so I
think we're after a long Halloween I
think so yeah
someone say something
whoa dang
it's your buoy knife I have pointy ones
too Green Arrow wait
look
are you a Green Lantern I'm not here to
fight I just want to get rid of this
thing
powering who is your previous owner
Green Lantern Hal Jordan oh
how Jordan is dead who are you how did
you get a friend's ring my name is John
Stewart and if I told you you wouldn't
believe me uh Try Us you're on a space
station with like powered people
Justice League I'm a martian I just like
extended my neck at you perhaps this is
connected to those disturbances in deep
space we cannot leave Earth unprotected
I am the only one qualified to
administrate the Watchtower yes can any
of you get this ring off me so it should
be possible unless the Ring's
programming was changed but these
Guardians they could get it off they did
create the power rings they do have some
dish soap and some warm water and
patience yes then I'm going to this old
place with you you got a problem with
that talk to the hand a giant hand comes
out you're both green you'll make the
perfect team everyone's fine with this
other else worlds where Green Arrow is
also a lantern yeah yeah there's a
couple extra now that I think of it you
seem to know your way around actually
I've never seen it before but Hal once
explained to me that the real measure of
any advanced technology is how intuitive
it is to use
a good point that is a good way to
explain something like that in a
sentence yeah talk to your ring we'll
just ask it for directions don't in fact
just tell it to put them into the ship's
autopilot and get us moving
can you do it unlocking systems
integrated coordinate set
the very fun origin story so far for him
yeah I like Regis diving right in they
decided a police force was necessary to
keep order these they called Green
Lanterns yes
getting Cosmic
oh this is why they haven't returned our
calls
good thing I've got a bow and arrow for
a second I thought I was just gonna
shoot the one on the ground let's just
make sure double tap double tap
everything here is built around that
building
no like it's important to something
maybe we'll find some answers there nice
to see you're not useless so encouraging
Oliver Sinestro he trained Hal and
become the greatest Green Lantern ever
he turned into an evil psycho I'm
guessing they left that part out when
they gave the tour
this place was wrecked because they
tried to take the statue down
this is what lanterns used to recharge
their rings you'll need one I'm here to
get rid of this thing remember better to
be prepared
hey this is really fun as I first Green
Lantern movie but especially with there
being none others in the universe like
and the other Universe either the only
Lantern
oh
whoa
Hawk Girl
hey
make a stronger Shield nice that's
clever
nice
force is not authorized
lethal force is now you're killing her
come on man snap out of it I am shyara
Hall Warrior of thanagar first order
Iranian ship it must have carried one of
their kill squads instead of the
diplomats listed in the logs or maybe
they were Diplomat Killers my ship was
destroyed in battle I came to seek aid
from the Guardians and our war against
the honorless ranians but was too late
oh place already wrecked after
bloody war we finally achieved the
tenuous peace thanagar and ran agreed to
a joint project led by sardath and
panther damn Zeta beam technology would
be harnessed to create a bridge between
our worlds and boost both of our
economies thumbs cool guys gonna fly
back
oh it was like the bifrost the project
was a great success great success very
nice my wife
what did you do beard man
are you doing another test come on Hal
something has gone wrong what was your
first clue you must stop the platform
from firing get a giant cork stand right
in front of it
whoa
jeepers
[Music]
Lantern's light
how do you can
transported the entire planet of
thanagar into Iranian space upsetting
the ecosystem of both planets uh yeah
uh-huh how do you know it wasn't an
accident and this ship doesn't prove
anything a true warrior does not ask
questions they do not hesitate they kill
that's a murderer yeah they're
describing different word use I thought
you wanted to get rid of it but you both
need me to make the ship go to some
place where they might be sharing well
yeah I mean probably more than likely
almost definitely actually
ring at three percent power where's the
battery ah can we get a fast charge
version of this it's our wireless I can
just it's not doing anything you got to
say the oath repeat after me in
Brightest Day in Blackest Night no evil
shall Escape my sight let those who
worship evils might be where my power
Green Lanterns light you're kidding
right no I am not also rhyme say it out
loud and proud
I love green arrow in this
yeah
damn
so charged up lanterned power at 800
percent
cool dude so many of these backgrounds
yeah beautiful sci-fi fantasy art I mean
they had to go to Tatooine where you go
it's required
the Ranny and scum have murdered the
thanagarians sent to destroy them you
sounds like you both have an intolerance
issue yeah a little judgmental there
thanagarian
oh
no Adam Strange
oh I'm excited when they said Randy and
I hope you got him strange you're gonna
like him he's crazy I'm excited I know
nothing
does everyone here want to kill each
other yes War common theme this movie
damn
nice we need to question it
of course
interrogation first
then execution sure whatever you say
just put the instrumental down
uh he's like the ultimate sci-fi space
fantasy OG character what was that
bright light that brought you here he's
a Green Lantern aren't they allies of
yours answer Thor
until his people killed the Guardians
first things first the bright light it
was a Zeta beam they seem attracted to
me I don't know why oh they transport me
to different far-reaching parts of the
Galaxy I have little control over them
that is very inconvenient but I'm Adam
Strange Adam Strange is dead a Zeta beam
took me and I couldn't figure out how to
get back so how are you here now random
chance random
Iranians would never attack owa okay
then let's go to your high command and
see if you're right our answers will be
found on ran and so will my vengeance
kill everyone when I get there I do love
that both major universes have a just a
highly skilled bow and arrow guy just
keep up with Gods I know they're both
like snarky every man that just hang I
may be able to access the main computer
with a scan of my DNA
oh yeah they they love you
I love Green Arrow it's me Adam Strange
he's dead scan me and see the truth he
got better
the senegarian is your prisoner you ran
it she's helping solve a mystery that
affects both ran and thanagar but we
need your help can we tap into your
ship's computers listen to Kurt Russell
in the thing yeah I do RJ McCready knows
what's up greatest scientist is building
a weapon that will destroy
death where only a few key people know
I'm not
you sure can you do anything to get the
battle cruiser moving again rerouting
power to the cattle engines is possible
it may be enough to defeat the
gravitational pull of the Red Dwarf do
it accordion Cola do it do it Randy and
battle cruiser has escaped the red
dwarf's gravitational pull thank you
Adam Strange onward for Ron dude ah
come on man last moments he's going back
to the battle his ship is useless what
what he hope to do got a Death Wish
Kamikaze now witness me
dude dude not a good guy a noble death
in battle
for everyone involved
well I guess we can agree on something
oh man oh man
when the Zeta beam transported thanagar
into rand's atmosphere it caused
catastrophic climate disasters yeah
the planet survived and that's what
started the war The Day After Tomorrow
Dennis Quaid saved them now sardath has
re-engineered the Zeta beam into a
weapon of total Destruction we were
examining the data on the attack on owa
oh
that we exam the drive signature it left
behind it was identical to a ship that
bombarded the United Galactic Council
headquarters years ago whoa
was a thanagarianship and that same ship
signature was also found at the scene of
many more unwarranted attacks someone
false flagging you guys calculated the
direction the drive signatures left
after many such attacks the ship headed
in this direction and if we triangulate
the Escape Routes they all meet here in
this sector
I actually like that they haven't made
earth-centric uh Fergus Green Lantern
it's always weird that they're like we
gotta go to Earth yeah cosmic's the move
well and this is very much like a space
police kind of situation yeah artificial
gravity and oxygen well since they made
it so hospitable let's go pay him a
visit that asteroid
I can go with that ring
[Music]
oh open your third eye yellow's not good
bro
fight it the color of fear fight it with
your will
oh
nice drop your weapons or this Green
Lantern becomes green slime
sir while we're on the subject
I think I'll relieve you of this no
with your lack of experience you give
new meaning to the name Green Lantern
why don't you just kill us because I
have a use for you we could dig our way
out good thing I've got a head start hey
Jesus Christ Our Lord and Savior you and
McGregor we came looking for you after
your ring turned up on his finger his
name's John Stewart or J Stu for short
Sinestro we think he disguised his ship
as Iranian vessel and attacked them he
sabotaged Stardust Grand experiment uh
ah sure I was asked to keep watch on
sarda's experiment Sinestro infiltrated
the base Nick is Nikki I was pulled onto
the planet before teleported with
everyone else before I passed out I
released my ring so Sinestro couldn't
get it he's got it now oh yeah
Immaculate ABS still show it you cowards
his Lantern's light
sardath is going to use Zeta beams as a
mega weapon he's trying it out in a
secret location only the Ronnie and Hike
a man knows where Los Alamos thank you
for all that information see uh you were
useful after all no matter how much of
an assault you launch on ran their
defenses are too good what a splendid
idea Don't Mind If I Do would an
instrumental knife help the hardest
substance in the universe
yeah might come in handy
yeah
jump on it that's handy
I'll fire up the engines we need to get
the ring what come on all you've done is
complain about it now you want it
it doesn't matter where the ring is
it'll find a way to get to him close
your eyes and will it back yeah and
Sinestro probably put it with all of our
other weapons see if we can grab those
up too
huh you probably can make a big net but
there's yellow
in green there is what does blue do blue
Curry blue there are blue lanterns
I forget which color switch
[Music]
ring do we have enough fuel to make a
jump to warp speed inconclusive that's
wonderful
[Laughter]
it's like a Ryan Reynolds energy but I
know it's not him yeah it's definitely
someone in that vein though yeah the
snark is strong
real good snark maybe Nolan North could
be I he does a lot of these yeah Adam
Strange calling Ronnie and high command
Commander strange is no longer it's Adam
are you still terrible at jackarak
by her lady's Grace it is you open a
window on the shield for us to get
through the window will open for two
seconds be good at this annihilate them
that's an astro
I'm out yeah yeah nicely done we've
uncovered a plot by a band of Rogue
agents to start and keep this war going
between our worlds they're the ones
firing on you now that ship is not then
agario we never thought to check
guys no you just call out that plot hole
did you just say it out loud no we
didn't think to to check any data
whatsoever we just hate those guys so
much instead of just just completely
overlooked that really hate those guys
don't deploy your weapon how do you know
about billions of innocent lives are at
stake it can't be used but my weapon is
the only thing that will stop the
thanagarians from killing more of us
easy Oppenheimer it was the analysis of
your unique biology that made it
possible to isolate your meta Gene
metagine our new Zeta energy always
found you
[Music]
oh and that was my first breakthrough
does it matter human I gained some
control over where those eight of beings
went a Mediterranean he just breaks the
fourth wall a lot now I command vast
amounts of say to energy at will no one
man stab all that power
into a supernoob it's the kingdom of God
I'm here to prevent you from making a
terrible mistake your first Zeta
experiment was sabotaged it caused this
war what are you talking about we're
being approached by
no guys
by the power of mattress yes
I got like a missile he's gonna throw at
him yes
fans is agile
come on Obi-Wan
triple tap
how poked out he likes murder now
no time to be soft pal I wonder if it's
gonna go Parallax at the end of this I
can see it I mean it's pretty pretty
merciless it's an interesting dichotomy
The Duality between good and evil this
is a little duplicitous yeah
ooh pound it keep losing that bro rock
it keeps happening
destroying the last of the Green
Lanterns
that's that's not gonna do it I feel
like it's pretty achievable to summon it
with willpower
use the force yes
shoot it through his body yeah yeah
smart
oh
like the quarter In First Class went
right nice yeah damn that's hard my
master
will kill you all
who are you working for
cool I like the way they animate this
guy's motion yeah every couple frames
they just nope
oh
jetpack a good name yeah Wonder Woman's
bracelets on ah the gauntlets sargath
isn't going to use the weapon he's
handing over the CPU containing the core
of his Zeta technology to me I don't
believe that the code is downloading to
this unit the only other place where
this knowledge is stored is my mind it's
excellent
wow what the hell what the hell man
a lot of work to be done
and damn you'll have to do better than
that we had it all backwards he wasn't
sinestro's prisoner Hal was his master
dang I have him to thank for my
transformation he was the stepping stone
so I could fulfill my true calling oh no
with these oh God he's like one of those
guys who runs a carnival ride
that's the cover of the comic that was
cool
that is badass and horrifying yellow and
green United
naked Hal
ey convinced him after the experimental
cutscene here the Sinestro infected me
with an Alien Parasite whoa he called it
The Parallax entity
there it is there you go there it is I
think you've read a comments you know
that I like him he thought it would bend
me to his will but instead it opened my
eyes and I immediately grew a beard
had to be done it was cool too long I
had been blind to the corrosive effect
of war and conflict
no no I saw clearly that I was the one
destined to change it I could be a
better Guardian than the Guardians there
was no use for them anymore centralize
all power to me I didn't have to wear
pants because no one was there I like
how naked this universe has been I think
each one is a Superman yeah had a mud
all the time he became my main
jeez man
Super Saiyan Hal Jordan do you think the
carpet also glowed yellow oh for sure
they kept that frame High yeah
I love the the yellow on impact with the
green
yeah it's really cool flourish
and his like the lighting as he moves
around yeah
join me in making a new and better
Galaxy my only choice is to stop you or
die try
yeah my only choice is you're a
geez why fight me aren't I doing exactly
what you do if you were in my place I
can see it in your eyes Tomorrow Never
Dies no you're wrong
damn
it's locked we'll never get through on
time I forgot the password
tried too many times for 30 seconds 45
seconds of lockdown it can't be stopped
but maybe it can be redirected what are
you saying shyara keep an eye on the
universe for me while I'm gone
I like you as allies
it's Brightest Day yeah
no evil shall Escape my sight
worship evils might yes beware my power
Strega punch them
[Music]
full suit that's great
yes come on buddy I finally remembered
why I fight
yes and why whatever price I have to pay
I'm okay with it
oh take an eye out maybe the Guardians
made the right choice by making me a
Green Lantern
ah the beams locked in
we tried everything we can think of damn
it missed one
oh no of course you're too soft to be a
lantern
oh buddy
hey Sally look
oh
okay
oh for you Alana
don't worry
no I mean yeah but no for Iranian he was
very brave
there's a high compliment thanks for the
ride shyra now there's just one more
thing left to do
rebuild the Green Lantern Corps
dang go out there and find your worthy
suitors congratulations hero you're a
Green Lantern how's it feel I'm starving
let's get something to eat and toast our
apps and friends and maybe a few new
ones let's go to bibos
who was Ollie dude that was so good that
was Trey legitimate I want to know I
want to know absolutely oh my God I was
I like this tomorrow verse man yeah
that's been great so far big fan enjoyed
every single installment very consistent
first three yeah
and really like interesting takes on
each of the characters really nicely big
and cinematic yeah and already
established like it's already in
universe
and like it seems like at least from my
vantage point in keeping with the oh
here we go Aldous Hodge Simpson was
Green Arrow sweets I can hear it now but
I wouldn't have guessed it ever
no one North was Hal though oh that's
right that was close just wrong yeah
yeah
I know like I love that eldest wasn't
Hawkman he was I know
girl as hell that's great you know he he
asked her for some tips yeah they had to
talk about sanitarian's on set of course
or actually I mean given when this came
out they were probably a production like
similar times yeah it probably talks
about nymph metal oh um but yeah it
seems like these tomorrow verse joints
so far have had like a nice grip on like
here are classic tenets of these
characters but we're also going to kind
of
uh like the Batman and Superman ones you
know it's like Superman you meet him in
a slightly different version of the
story and you meet him part way through
the origin sure and then Batman you're
doing long Halloween so that's like he's
already fledged and established and
you're seeing this one specific sort of
swath of time and then here it's like
you know you do have the origin like
this is an origin story for uh Jon
Stewart it feels like and yeah something
that you know I don't know it seems like
it
I don't know as much about Green Lantern
and some of the other characters but it
seemed like it really kind of used all
those core tenets but then also made it
this interesting broadly Cosmic kind of
no not
super deep but you know like a
commentary on
War tensions and the deceits of War and
the ways in which you know both sides of
a conflict can have these skewed views
of one another and be manipulated by
outside forces and so like starting off
you know with these traumatic memories
of his time in Afghanistan yeah and then
launching him into this situation where
you've got this Cosmic war between these
two warring factions of people who you
know shouldn't really be at odds this is
2022. yeah so this is definitely wild
definitely eldest Hodge was yeah
probably not even wrapped yeah yeah
that's crazy I mean some overlap and now
we got them all sharing uh roles so like
Aldous if he got to stay would be
Hawkman yeah uh yeah I'm really curious
how the tomorrow Universe goes with it
being ongoing and with uh
James Gunn's like everyone cast will be
yeah I wonder if they'll else worlds
that or if or if his because I mean they
have again more tomorrow verse films
slated at least in 2024 I want to say is
it going to do crisis on infinite Earths
and they have I think I mean I don't
know if it's in the continuity but I
mean DC animated has Watchmen I think
coming up yeah um so I'm really excited
for us to catch up and watch it new yeah
right because yeah because then we'll
get to a point where it's just like new
animated movies yeah jump on it you know
and we do have some fun stuff coming uh
that people don't know about with some
other things you'll have requested might
be getting more than just the one
animated movie with some others like
you'll soon if it hasn't already aired
if it has an idea we don't what order is
any of this
um I really really dug that I didn't
know Adam Strange was gonna be in this
uh There's a comic called strange
Adventures that is uh I've talked about
him before Tom King uh Tom King wrote a
12 issue uh Maxi series about Adam
strange but he did a really cool thing
where
um one storyline is with one artist and
one storyline is with another artist and
you get to see subjective versus
objective kind of like with Oppenheimer
how oh color versus black and white it's
one artist doc trainer and one artist Mr
rods doing different parts of the story
so you can interpret the war crimes of
like how what how much is that a war
crime it's a really good book and a lot
is still alive in it um it's beautifully
done um but it's about like the the
conflict of The Iranians and uh and what
you know you what what lengths to go
where it's still justified in war yeah
I love uh
I would love to see more of that
character because just this is my first
introduction to the whole world
and that seemed like he was just such a
cool compelling presence on screen does
he always look like that yeah well he's
got the beard in some timeline he's also
got this very clean cut like George
Clooney like he's like the classic 50s
swashbuckling almost Rocketeer sure so
like a space Rocketeer character's a guy
who's always kind of out on some
Adventure yeah and flying solo and
getting into almost like wandering
Warriors yeah it's very Star Trek uh and
it's kung fu yeah in that like deep
space like I'm the guy with the gun and
man like that like more classic comic uh
uh of the 50s and earlier tropes see
that's the thing I love part of what I
loved so much about this was that it had
this nice juxtaposition of like you're
dealing with a war conflict again you're
dealing with these false flag scenarios
and you're dealing with all this like
Grim deception but then you also have
this stuff that's that does feel very
sci-fi serial and very fantasy sci-fi
like some of these beautiful people just
Planet Scapes that they have even when
they're wrecked just like the designs
and the mood and the tone and yeah
taking it like you pointed out in during
the movie was you know they always seem
to want to bring it to Earth for so many
things and I feel like I can definitely
see that being a problem with you know
doing some Lantern stuff and so yeah I
like that it's like this felt like an
appropriate origin for Hal yeah uh or
sorry for John for Jon Stewart
um but it was also an ensemble movie and
it's also you know about more than that
without ever feeling like either one is
getting slighted yeah I feel like the
way they introduced John was perfect for
John but Hal didn't feel like they just
used him to get rid of him they they
gave a new take on a character a lot of
people know yeah and it makes for some
fun dramatic Dynamics because you have a
person you're designed to trust how and
then you have other characters who
obviously you don't like sinestra but
then you also have guys in the middle
like the scientist developing the the
big Zeta beam weapon and you're like I
don't know if I like them or do I trust
this Dune guy yeah like once he's uh you
know dispatched you're like okay I think
that guy was just kind of doing his
thing he just was like suspicious of
what was happening yeah yeah yeah so
it's like this is really conscientious
and I like that you know you have that
brief moment with the Justice League you
get a little bit of Martian Man who's
got more time in this universe in three
movies and he wasn't even in one of them
it's so weird he feels like a much
stronger presence oh no he only has this
one scene but you're like we loved him
in the last one so it's like I feel that
that residual presence yeah and who was
that with him was that Vixen there's a
vixen credit oh yeah yeah Vixen was the
the woman in the the powers that should
go through yeah um and that was like a
surprise did not expect her yeah so she
must have joined between movies it's
like it's cool yeah right I wonder if
she'll become more of a character but uh
it just had this this lovely quality
where yeah I never felt like it was you
know like taking time I know right like
and I loved his performance here and I
never would have expected a green arrow
I thought was again like a character I
wouldn't necessarily expect to be the
guy show like I would expect Martian
Manhunter to Shepherd uh yeah Jon
Stewart around during this journey so to
have him as your eye line to have him as
like your most normal guy throughout all
this uh I thought was a great choice was
solid yeah I want Jamie Simpson and Sam
Rockwell to play Brothers sure yeah
that's the thing I want um I really
liked this introduction for Jon Stewart
uh Altus Hodge crushed obviously but
getting to see Jon Stewart uh get his
own movie was exciting because I we
literally knew so little we were
describing it as a hell Jordan movie
before it because that was the
Assumption um but like I really really
like uh when Jon Stewart gets his own
time to shine like not as a sidekick
like a lot of really good Jon Stewart
Comics are him having to make hard
wartime decisions because they they lean
into that element and with Jon Stewart
being confirmed for the show the live
action show I'm really curious
um if it is like I said like the core
the Green Lantern Corps has been
destroyed and you're trying to solve
like murder mystery because True
Detective is a very specific tone to
model something after so I'm like is it
going to be Sinestro taking out lanterns
is it gonna be like a murder mystery
like it's just it's all really exciting
yeah and I thought that was a cool again
I am familiar with the concept of the
core I've seen many an image yeah and so
for this to be an introduction for this
to be pretty much like the first Green
Lantern Centric focused thing I'm
watching really I haven't even seen the
Ryan Reynolds movie which I know is a
perfect adaptation easily one of the
best comedy films of all time 10 out of
10. and I mean he goes out of his way to
make us remember all the time that's why
he was like free guy is a sequel about
me and taika teaming up again of course
because he was my
he was a very entitled part of that
Green Lantern experience which everyone
knows launched the DC Universe they
didn't wreck on it to make Superman the
first one no no it is it is Canon uh and
I and I appreciate that here they they
managed to take make that something I
don't know it's like
as if I was a person who was well versed
in this going into a new universe I can
imagine maybe being taken aback of like
they're all gone they're like no no
answers at all but like I like the idea
of having this be this mantle that John
has to take up but then you get the
prospect of all the Rings go out into
the universe and find the new core yeah
and then you can rebuild without it
being like titled continuity yeah and
coming out of the DC AMU experience yeah
into this I'm like oh that's really cool
though because even though this is its
own timeline already it's just yeah it
gets that excitement of new prospects
going really sort of uh organically
there's been three of these and all
three I think would be excellent to
adapt to live action for the new DCU
because first one was a young Superman
that gives you his origin without being
an origin which we don't we know the
origin but establishes him in a world
that isn't Alexa Luther is the big bad
the second one is Batman in a family
element which we know we are getting and
this is a Jon Stewart story where you
don't sacrifice Hal by like all three of
these would be great DCU kickoffs well
and the whole thing with Hal when is he
called is The Parallax like and that
like I thought that was a really cool
and you know I should have known about
10 minutes earlier as soon as he had a
beard I knew early but I should have
known earlier they tricked us with the
Jesus
and I was like man I want to trust him
yeah and that I mean seems like a choice
a bold Choice certainly motivated by
Comics choice but I feel like here again
having come out of so many of these
dcamu movies having seen Hal so many
times having had so many phillions
uh I thought it was a really cool way to
go one step further than like oh yeah
Sinestro of course right whereas here
it's like oh damn this is like personal
just to the concept of Green Lantern and
him with like the and Nola
oh that was right from the comic cover
that it happened
but I love that Nolan North is usually
like your snarky good guy like you know
Deadpool's not a bad guy I was anti-hair
but like Nolan North usually plays the
snarky good so I think that casting was
really solid for Hal because you're like
I'm actually Hoodwinked because he's so
Charming yeah totally yeah yeah the
voices were great across the board I
thought I had a great time with this
this universe has been solid for me I
know a lot of people weren't as
enthralled with this Universal as the uh
the last but both have been solid I
think DC the reputation DC has for their
animated movies is very Justified uh the
bar is high cannot wait for the next
because these are all so good and we are
catching up to modern day we got some
other surprises like I said for you so
stay tuned hit that subscription Bell so
you know what's coming before we get out
of here let's give some love to a
patreon remember if you guys head over
to patreon you can watch this in their
entirety watch us experience every
moment but it is a Green Lantern so
let's give it up for a certain uh well
there's a there's a clear name to me
because uh one of the Green Lanterns
that was just cast is a guy Gardener oh
and it would seem to me that a Chase
guard would be related to guy so Chase I
hope uh your uncle Guy Gardner is at
least kind to you he's a bit of a prick
uh I know he can be a lot to deal with
his heart sometimes in the right place I
don't even want to say always in the
right place
yeah I think Chase is really I mean
clearly Chase is good people as a patron
100 but uh if you could tell guy to uh
be kinder uh less selfish and get a
better haircut that would mean a lot to
us that Orange Bowl cut it had its time
and uh may we all move on so Chase
Gardner thanks for being a patron and
thank you for all of your hair styling
advice you're gonna give your uncle we
appreciate it
all right that is gonna do it your
lovelies we're gonna wrap this out we
will see you next week for something
else and maybe something's owner I'm
excited I'm very excited about the other
thing but uh we'll see you very soon and
I cannot wait to do more of these as
always an absolute pleasure John these
are so much fun yeah man thank you what
a good time what a good time we've
always through so much we have and we
have so much and we're gonna go back and
forth in time much like Comics do much
love reject Nation we'll see you very
soon
thank you